other news here at six a teenager shot
and killed inside a home while he was
with his friends on thursday tonight the
police are trying to find out why the
15-year-old's family spoke with candace
charles today and candace they told you
he had gone there apparently right after
school
that's right brian good evening folks
yes the family tells me and police that
he was at a home he was familiar with
when he was shot and killed details as
to why are still unknown but the family
tells me they hope that the
investigation will reveal answers to the
questions they still have
when i was ready for this none of those
were ready for her
it's not expected a tragedy that never
should have happened george gomez tells
me his 15-year-old brother walter junior
hildago had gone to an apparent friend's
house after school before the shooting
everybody was at work everybody was
doing their normal thing then the
terrible news that junior had been shot
police say it happened inside a house
here on coleman street near the corner
of alexander and simmons thursday
evening medical personnel did arrive on
scene and the male juvenile did succumb
to his injuries and was pronounced dead
on scene the young man's death shocking
the neighbors those kids are very
respectful that live there
wonderful kids it's always yes ma'am no
sir you know whatever whoever's talking
to them so we've never had no problems
with them so i really don't know what
happened with no answers the family
tells me the pain is overwhelming it's
so hard
it breaks my
[Music]
hair it's such a sad and unfortunate
story and police are still investigating
what exactly happened in the home once
we know more details we'll be sure to
share with them with you so stick with
us right here on air online and on
social for the latest for now live in
north las vegas i'm candace charles 8
news now